if you're like me you finished arcane
and was like
fear not a tweet from the official
arcane account just announced that
season two is in production but to tie
this over until then i've compiled as
many easter eggs that i could find from
season one and there are a lot so lock
in your champion make sure to like and
subscribe and if you haven't seen my
full season 1 video with theories on
season 2 i've left a link to it in the
description below starting with episode
1 the song that plays at the very
beginning makes reference to rivers and
towers both key map elements found in
the league of legends video game check
out these cupcakes found on the rooftop
of piltover which look a lot like the
ones found in bittersweet lulu's skin
cupcakes can also be found in the final
dinner banquet scene as well as what vai
calls caitlyn in episode 5. you're hot
cupcake even crazier if you play as vi
in the game and dodge caitlyn's ultimate
you're treated with this special
interaction
nice shot cupcake speaking of vai she's
the first real champion that we see in
the show unless you count vander who's
likely to become warwick in season 2. if
you want to know a little bit more about
that check out my season 1 video as
powder escapes you'll see these small
teemo mushrooms as graffiti on the side
of some of the houses check out this
shot from one of piltover's town squares
here you can make out the statue known
as the rudentera incognium it was
created by a scientist named zindelo but
he disappeared before this device could
perform its real function which was to
find anyone in runeterra now it kind of
just sits there as a statue kinda like
me at thanksgiving dinner down in the
underground the area where vai and the
gang live is called the lanes referring
to the three lanes you'll find in league
here we'll be introduced to two more
champions echo and singed at least this
singed is before he gets his face all
burned in a shimmer explosion that
happens in episode 3. buried in the
market are these easter egg looking eggs
i wonder if they have anything to do
with the teemo easter bunny skin you can
also make out a stone elemental creature
known as a krug from legends of
runeterra in benzo's shop you'll see
rabadon's death cap and item from the
game and over here you can see some
items that have since been removed like
the eye of ascension leandre's torment
and haunting guys i wasn't sure what the
mask on the left was so if you know
please leave a comment and as ekko
leaves the shop take a look at what's
over the doorframe yep mordekaiser's
helm episode 2 sees the use of
teleportation a major component of the
league of legends game other than this
scene we don't really see it utilized
that much it's here we meet young jace
now there's a lot of speculation around
who saved jason as mother the dominant
theory out there is that it's ryze who
is on a mission to collect world runes
we also see these rune markings on his
fingers but you might be asking yourself
i thought ryze's skin color was blue
actually there is a ryze skin called
young rise which shows him in his human
form and this is more in line with what
we see on the show but back to jace his
father ran the talus hammer business
which explains his iconic weapon which
will later be imbued with hextech and
there's heimerdinger whose assistant is
another champion victor and check out
this cool teemo video game in vander's
hideout there also appears to be a
gangplank inspired shooting range and
i'm not sure if these statues are
supposed to be cassiopeia cassie casey
hope cassiopeia whatever in this family
portrait of the kirimans you can see
caitlyn started shooting at a young age
holding this rifle in episode 3 amongst
a collection of jinx's things we can see
vi's full name violet this can also be
seen in episode 6 in the rubble of their
hideout in the back you can make out
these two colored wings a reference to
star guardian jinx check out these
shimmer barrels where you can make out
gragas's image on progress day we see
this undersea helmet and i just get
total nautilus vibes we also get a
demonstration of the hex claw which will
later become a key component of victor's
gear later we'll see jason heimerdinger
admiring the statue of stanwick pedidley
he was a former professor who in lol
lore resurrected ergot and stole credit
away from victor for his work in
creating blitzcrank now i thought this
was kind of interesting this is a
fish-like character we see now i know
fizz is supposed to be an amphibious
yordle but i wonder if this is the same
species or something else entirely now
this one might be a bit of a stretch at
first i thought this was nasus the shape
of the head the golden green colors and
the eye of horus egyptian-like symbol on
his hands this eye is called the eye of
zahn in runeterra lore and can be seen
later on in episode 6. nasus was
considered a demi-guide by the shirema
and here you can see a bunch of people
holding what appears to be eyes
worshiping him again it doesn't really
look like him but someone related to the
sharima people zuyan who is known as one
of the ascended who took the form of a
turtle this could totally be coincidence
but a few seconds later we see a
crocodile giving me total renekton vibes
and renekton is the brother of nasus we
also see a man's back being tattooed
with the symbol for a pentakill check
out this wooden rhino here in jinx's
hideout it resembles the same rhino
found in the get jinxed music video
while in the brothel we see these two
unknown individuals wearing kindred
masks and behind this absolutely sexy
yordle is a mask of blood moon twisted
fate when vi is walking through the
underground and imagined dragon song
plays with the actual band animated top
side we have an almost operatic like
performance in the style of the frail in
the roon terra universe the freljord
takes inspiration from norse mythology
caitlyn's truth card here looks like
some sort of vampire at first i thought
it could be vladimir but it's probably
just silco considering where the pin is
pointing to on the map in the next
episode where she goes hunting with
grayson her bullets are engraved with
her family's crest at an underground
food stand we get this delicious
creature which looks like it could be
related to gromp one of the jungle
creatures in league of legends in
marcus's daughter's room we get a brief
look at one of her books which contains
a bunch of teemos caitlyn finds this
shimmer addict who you may recognize as
huck the man vander save from those two
thugs in episode 1. in episode 6 we see
madarada painting something this turns
out to be the immortal bastion which is
under control of the noxus empire where
she hails from and another little teemo
here at the firelight space this is
pretty funny but a lot of people have
been saying this looks like an among us
character pretty suss if you ask me the
beginning of episode 7 has this stylized
intro featuring the fire lights check
out this letter z which kinda looks like
an hourglass interesting since echo z
drive has the ability to reverse time
this z drive is seen later on but it's
never had a power source quite like one
of these gemstones so it'll be
interesting how this comes into play in
season 2. check out these mechanical
dragonflies on jinx's table she actually
stole these from the progress day
festival in episode 4 and they'll go on
to be engineered as bombs in the bridge
bombing scene of episode 7. speaking of
that bridge when jinx arrives she hums
the same song that played at the
beginning of episode 1 where her parents
died with the arrival of mel's mother
ambassador medarda we learn mel's
brother has died this is likely jay
madarda who can be found in the legends
of runeterra card game when silco drinks
underneath the statue of vander we can
see ekko's name etched there the zanites
like creating memorials and paying
homage to the dead as referenced here
along the bridge and at the firelight
base okay i gotta put this in here it's
not really an easter egg but i love
skye's signature in the final episode we
see singed holding a pocket watch which
may be of his daughter orianna i get
more in depth with this in my season 1
ending explain video at the dinner
banquet vi is given a makeshift music
box by jinx the same music box powder
stole from jace's shop in episode 1.
jinx's rocket fish bones looks quite
similar to one of the pillows found in
the last drop's basement in that same
episode now i'm sure there are more
easter eggs out there if i've left
something out please leave a comment and
let me know what you thought of arcane
season 1. thanks for watching everyone
make sure to like and subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
twitter and instagram at thinkstoryyt
until next time remember daddy loves you
very much
you